what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so at the time that I'm recording this
video right now I I just finished
watching the flash and God it was an
amazing episode I'm not gonna spoil it
for anybody who hasn't seen it yet
although the video is probably gonna be
going up today fYI I actually record my
videos about a week before you guys see
them and sometimes I'll upload them and
make them unlisted and then people will
just be like a secret video like they'll
find it and they'll be super excited
which by the way I've actually got a
video on my channel no one's found it
yet and I'm curious to see whether or
not you guys can find it but I have a
video up on my channel that's been up
for a month and no one knows that it's
there like it's kind of funny I was just
testing to see how it is that you guys
find my secret videos and it's and it's
kind of weird but anyway so after
reading the Free Comic Book Day version
are is really the Free Comic Book Day
release of Captain America secret Empire
what I wanted to do is I really want to
kind of go back a little bit because
with with secret Empire I mean you
really could just pick up with all-new
all-different marvel just kind of start
with the Avengers and then read like you
know Avengers vol 1 and then like
Captain America Sam Wilson vol 1 then
Avengers stand off and then Captain
America Steve Rogers you could go in
that order and read those stories but in
truth I think it all really kind of
dates back to Rick Remender run the
reason why I'm doing this is because of
the fact that for those of you guys who
are new to Captain America
you know like Hydra Captain America is
the first time you've picked him up I
want you guys to be able to have a sort
of foundation I want you guys to be able
to look and to see why there are so many
people who are up in arms about Captain
America and I feel like Rick Remender
Run that starts really with Steve Rogers
being trapped in dimension Z and then
coming back and then fighting iron nail
and then losing the Super Soldier Serum
and getting old I think a lot of those
things really kind of encapsulate what
makes Captain America what he is so for
the next three weeks or so we're gonna
run through all that stuff it'll be like
every other day or something like that I
mean we're back to alternating all-new
all-different marvel and DC rebirth
every other day of the week so it'll
come pretty fast like I mean we'll roll
through it and within a week and a half
but initially this kind of picks up with
the Lower East Side of Manhattan in 1926
and it picks up with the early days of
Captain America now a lot of people have
really redone Captain America's origin
in a lot of ways for example Captain
America White was an amazing story by by
Jeph Loeb I keep forgetting it was an
amazing story by Jeph Loeb and it was
really really good it kind of take a
look at Captain America I mean you know
Tim sales are was you know really cool
and everything but the fact remains here
that with Captain America
origin kind of being revamped so to
speak here by Rick Remender what it does
is it gives us a basis behind why he is
the way he is and over the years this
has been done in different ways I mean
different people have done it in in
different forms but the common theme
among the traditional Captain America
that you think of is that he is a guy
who stands up for those that can't stand
up for himself and again while the
origins could have been redone and not a
lot of people know the specifics about
what he was before he became Captain
America it was always just kind of taken
us that's what he is that's what he's
about he's the guy that stands up for
the weak what we end up getting here is
we end up basically finding out that his
father you know growing up in the Great
Depression was a very abusive man now I
wouldn't go as far as to say that he's
like every other man during the Great
Depression I don't know enough about
individual personalities during that era
to make that claim but what I can say is
the father of Steve Rogers was probably
one of several people out there you know
just having common sense that would tell
us it he basically lashed out at those
of us around him because keep in mind
during the Great Depression and
especially around that era the man was
the breadwinner I mean this was really
kind of long before World War two was
long before women were able to step into
the age of having jobs in the workplace
and running companies and so on and so
forth and so for the father of Steve
Rogers it was a pride thing it was the
sense that he just wasn't really able to
make the kind of money that he needed in
order to provide for his family
adequately now on the surface it seems
like an admirable thing but it's not and
the reason why is because in his anger
and in his irritation and his
frustration with his lot in life he
turns to alcohol and he abuses his wife
now Steve Rogers you know [ __ ] kind of
watches a lot of these things unfold and
we're not really given an indication
here at least and initially by Rick
Remender
that Steve Rogers father takes his hands
to Steve himself but his mother keeps
standing up keeps basically getting back
up again and refuses to fall down now
this is not Rick Remender saying oh yeah
it's not like that what it is is it's
giving Rogers the foundation because he
asks his mother why didn't you just stay
down and she replies because you always
stand back up no matter what happens you
always stand on your feet that is the
core of what makes Captain America what
he is and people who are fans of the
traditional Captain America are probably
like heartened by that little bit of a
description the probably kind of
hardened by that like yes
that is Captain America he is the guy
that always stands back up he will fight
until the bitter end now of course this
kind of transitions to the modern day
when he's just fighting some guy called
green skull and usually just like a
crazy environmentalist guy he just wants
to detonate some kind of bomb on earth
or you know in Manhattan little like you
know hyper evolved plants and turn
people into plants and we it's it's
weird it's nonsensical this is a design
to be some great big huge story or thing
it's design designed to be pretty based
I mean you know the guys defeated pretty
quickly he's handed over to the cops and
that's the end of that Steve Rogers goes
to meet Sharon Carter now a little bit
of an exposition here Sharon Carter's
kind of had a weird history over the
course of Marvel Comics there was a
point where she was the daughter of
Peggy Carter and then she was the niece
of Peggy Carter and a lot of that kind
of stuff was basically changed up
because of the chronology of Peggy
herself but the fact remains here that
with Peggy Carter having been the love
interest of Captain America during World
War two and the fact that it just wasn't
plausible it wasn't practical to have
the two of them together let's say 60
years later or something like that when
you know in the modern day it made more
sense to pair Steve Rogers off with
Sharon Carter so the two of them have
been a couple for quite some time and
really their relationship has kind of
evolved to the point where they're
talking about the idea of marriage now
for Steve Rogers and really what
recommender does here is he basically
provides the circumstance where Steve
just kind of like I don't know and it's
really kind of cool because he plays on
the hero archetype of Steve Rogers and
he really kind of gives us this idea
that Rogers doesn't really know how to
be a regular person in World War two
because I mean you got to think about it
from his perspective he grew up with an
abusive father so we had this intrinsic
drive to protect those that couldn't
protect themselves that became a reality
when he became Captain America he fought
in World War two he fought alongside the
invaders was frozen in ice for some 20
years he was thought out he joined the
Avengers and all he's done is fight as a
superhero since he's never been able to
sit down and kind of you know let his
hair down so to speak and just be a
normal human being it's always been one
adventure after the next the earth is in
danger New York is in danger the
universe is in danger there's always
been something going on that requires
him to be a superhero
and so when presented with the
opportunity to just be a man it's almost
scary
it's almost as kind of like exploring
this new part of himself that he's never
really had a chance to explore before
now all this doesn't really matter
anyway because of the fact that when he
gets on a subway train he's just kind of
whisked away to dimensions II now we're
not really told how or does
told that he is I'm sure it's just sort
of a it's a transition piece it doesn't
need to be super in-depth but his
arrival is met with Armin Zola he's
basically kind of knocked out he's
subdued and he wakes up in a lab now
semi to point out here is that Arnim
Zola being here in dimension Z it's just
a byproduct of the landscape of Marvel
comics after house of M which is to say
a lot of the characters are just kind of
revamped and they were adjusted and they
were kind of giving you stories and
different things like that and so
quantum Zola was just kind of vacant for
something like eight years you know that
originally he showed up here but with
regards to him having a robot body
this was actually fleshed out of a had
been established in Marvel for quite
some time
but it was basically fleshed out in
invaders now written by Christos Gage
and drawn by Alex Ross it's an
absolutely beautiful beautiful story but
what it does is it focuses on the
invaders during World War two like we
said you know Captain America Bucky
Barnes Jim Hammond and they were the
Submariner but the idea was that you
know when World War Two Arnim Zola was
just a guy he was just a crazy scientist
guy but eventually his physical body was
destroyed and he basically kept his own
mind intact in the form of a robot and
this is how he functioned for years and
years and years it was away from all
this kind of keep his character of going
with him staying a villain without
having the Super Soldier Serum and just
kind of keeping him alive because after
awhile if he didn't have the Super
Soldier serum or the infinity serum
which is what Nick Fury had in order to
keep himself young poornam Zola would
just grow old and eventually die so just
for the sake of practicality he was just
kind of given given a robot body but the
fact remains here that we also know
finding out that that Arnim Zola is
basically growing a child in an
incubation tank this is a young boy that
he's basically kind of growing into his
own for the purpose of absorbing that
are taking the Super Soldier Serum out
of Captain America and putting it in
this child of course Captain America is
able to free himself and he takes this
boy along with him we also end up
learning that Arnim Zola also has a
young girl named jet black now in truth
these are not children that he had
biologically produced with any
particular woman they're basically grown
they're engineered by Arnim Zola as is
everything within dimension Z dimension
Zola
all this stuff belongs to him the ships
the aliens a whole nine yards now a lot
of them were created and then just kind
of set out in the environment and they
were more or less just left there but
the idea is that in the midst of the
explosion Zola cannot find the child
cannot find his son and so his initial
thought is Captain America basically
killed him in the explosion but of
course as we know Captain America took
the boy with
and so for those of you guys who are
reading a little bit about Captain
America about him having his son that's
where this comes from that comes from
the whole dimension Z when he basically
rescues the child or takes the child
from Zola now the reason for this is
just Steve Rogers kind of being a
reasonable human being in the sense that
if Zola has a child under his control it
hits at home for Steve Rogers Zola is a
bad guy and he will basically turn this
child into a villain for all intents and
purposes and so because of that Rogers
is both serving as kind of a guardian of
this child and a surrogate father in the
sense that he names him Ian and he even
goes as far as to say that for the year
that they've been there because we
actually jumped forward by about a year
the year that they've been there they're
learning new things all the time Steve
Rogers is basically learning about this
entire place he's learning that you know
you have to be a really successful
hunter you have to learn to be able to
fend off on your own but the issue with
this is that this basically contradicts
directly with his desire to return home
because every waking dream that he has
every nightmare that he has is always
about the idea of getting back home to
Sharon Carter the problem with this is
that within his chest he has this
constant nagging pain now this is gonna
be kind of a recurring theme this
nagging burning sensation in his hand
it's gonna be an ongoing theme that
happens with regards to him you know
trying to cope with what's going on but
for the most part things are pretty
straightforward in the sense that he and
his son are just trying to navigate
throughout the different territories of
of dimension Z and they come across
different races they come across
different groups you know for example
they end up coming across a group that
calls themselves the frocks now the
frocks are just one of the various
species that exist in dimension Z that
serve the purpose of this kind of
opposing Arnim Zola now they do not
launch like campaigns against Zola just
because of the fact that you know with
with regards to Zola's fear of influence
and is the capital city and so on and so
forth they just don't have the abilities
to fend off against it but what
recommenders doing here is he's
basically saying this is just one of
those circumstances where we've stumbled
across a race that's just kind of grown
unto itself and that's really what Zola
did Zola would basically he was like a
like a prime mover he would create these
species he would set their evolution in
motion and then whatever happened
happened but again they were just kind
of designed in a way to where he could
monitor them to a degree but he did also
does kind of rule over a land of his own
now in the end Zola's goal is to also
basically take over earth and as you
know to invade the earth with his forces
so on and so forth but we end up fine
there's actually some some trouble in
paradise here there's some strife among
the ruling class of the frocks in the
sense that their existing leader is
really more of a tyrant that he's been
led than he's led his people to believe
um but it's also this idea that he's
kind of giving in to the existing rule
of zola which is to say but he's not
really leading a revolution now of
course Steve Rogers is able to activate
a universal translator that was
previously given to him by Hank Pym and
is able to understand what it is that
they're saying and this is where we end
up finding there's kind of a debate
between the various members of the Fox
in the sense that some of them view
Steve Rogers as a liberator as a guy
that opposes Arnim Zola and can in turn
help them be liberated from Arnim Zola
others view him as a guy whose sides
with Zola and is more of a spy now
ultimately those that view Rogers in a
positive light end up coming out on top
and the end result as it he actually
takes up residence with him to being by
the name of Zhou Shore and his wife and
the result is that he's kind of Todd you
know how to survive he's taught how to
fish taught the tools or the the skills
that he needs in order to make it in
dimension Z but ultimately this leads
directly to to a conflict between Oz off
shore and some of the other species when
Steve Rogers chimes in and says look if
you don't like Zola
then rise up against him now ultimately
you know the the response is that nobody
else wants to fight against a Zola just
because of the forces that he has is so
on and so forth but ultimately what ends
up taking place here is Roger says look
all it takes is one guy again kind of
harkening back to the lesson that his
mother taught him if you live on your
knees you're gonna be forced to exist on
your knees you know you're gonna be
forced to serve other people but if you
stand up and you die fighting then maybe
you'll become a martyr for something
else now this brings in a lot of
philosophical ideas about the nature of
conflict right I mean right now in in
secret Empire Captain America's the
tyrant you know Steve Rogers as an agent
of Hydra is the bad guy now we'll cross
that bridge in terms of retcons and so
on once we get to Avengers standoff but
for the time being it brings in a lot of
these philosophical arguments you know
for example people will say well martyrs
win wars well not really because they're
dead wars are won by the people who
fight long enough to win the war it
creates this kind of plenty situation
but then again what motivation would
they have to fight if they weren't led
by a martyr if they weren't inspired by
the actions of a martyr so it's really
kind of like all these different themes
come together to lead to a conflict as
we know it but again this agony in his
chest the searing pain in his chest that
he experiences time and time again once
he basically makes his escape is
revealed to be
Arnim Zola who planted himself inside
the body of Steve Rogers now again this
is kind of weird because this is what
Zola does Zola will basically jump from
one host body to the next in order to
keep himself alive now he still has his
physical body I mean he still has that
Bette robotic body but keeping himself
alive in Steve Rogers will allow him to
defeat Steve Rogers and the reason why
is because of the fact that fighting
Captain America is not just a physical
battle I mean it is in a lot of
different ways if you're super strong
Captain America is not going to be able
to face off against you The Incredible
Hulk versus Steve Rogers in a legit
fight Rogers is gonna lose every single
time it doesn't matter what his tactical
experience is but when it comes to
facing off against Captain America
somebody like Arnim Zola uses
psychological advantage and that's what
it is basically you know we end up
picking up 11 years after this
revelation again you know Rick Remender
kind of jumps us forward and we end up
finding out that with with armed Zola
inside the body of Steve Rogers he
constantly talks to him he constantly
taunts him now the reason why this is
significant is because of the fact that
Arnim Zola as he exists in Steve Rogers
is more or less equivalent to the
techno-organic virus now for those of
you guys who don't know in Marvel Comics
the techno-organic virus is basically a
virus that converts organic tissue into
machinery
it's what's attached to cable it's what
makes cable half of a robot he uses his
telekinetic and telepathic powers to
constantly keep the virus at bay that's
why he's not as powerful as he could be
that's why strife is so much more
powerful in cable because strife is
basically cable cloned without the
technolog Anik virus so he's everything
cable could be but in fact remains here
that within the realm of this particular
story Arnim Zola as is basically a virus
constantly trying to take over the body
of Captain America the difference here
is that Captain America
doesn't really have a tried-and-true way
of suppressing Arnim Zola with the
exception of whatever healing factor his
Super Soldier Serum offers and maybe
whatever kind of you know mental control
he can exert over his body if any at all
and so because of that Zola's just
slowly taking over the body of Steve
Rogers but along the way what he's
trying to do is he's coming to grips
with the fact that he might die now of
course he knows that if he gets back
home if he gets back to the main Marvel
Universe that he'll be able to go with
the Avengers and they'll be able to
remove Zola and the day will be saved
but on the off chance that he doesn't
make it on the off chance that he ends
up dying he's passing all these
important lessons on to Ian and doing
the best he can basically
you have to fight for those who can't
fight for themselves you have to work
for those who who are basically trying
to save themselves you know we're trying
to become a better person your role is
to be a hero and to be a leader instead
of a conqueror now of course this also
coincides with Arnim Zola basically
talking to Rogers about the true
heritage of Ian and the reason why is
because ian has grown up believing that
Steve Rogers is his father
and whenever the question was asked
where did I come from where's my mother
Rogers would always dodge the question
he would always divert his attention to
something else and as a child you know
as a pretty young kid Ian never really
had a reason to ask any questions but
now he's in his teenage years and the
result is that he's a little more angsty
he's a little more rebellious he wants
answers to the questions that he's been
asking but had been denied him for so
long and so because of that ultimately
we have Arnim Zola kind of speaking out
on behalf of Steve Rogers essentially
saying you were groaning in the lab you
are a kid who is basically just kind of
created you don't really belong to Steve
Rogers you're not his biological son
you're just kind of there now of course
this is crushing for Ian and this is
actually going to be one of the reasons
why Ian's effectively defects from Steve
Rogers which leads into the second half
which is escape from dimensions II but
the fact remains here that we also end
up picking up with jet black now again
jet black is basically the daughter of
Arnim Zola as we saw earlier in the
story the problem here is that Rick
Remender does not really expand much on
her character in terms of what she's
capable of all we know is that by virtue
of the trials that she had experienced
which are basically the lessons she
learns engaging in different combat
scenarios honing her skills she has what
are called omni senses now the idea here
is that she can basically transform any
one of her five senses into omni sense
so here I gets elevated to Omni sense
meaning elevated to the height of its
ability so she wanted to elevate her
sense of smell to the to its highest
point
she literally takes away from all the
other senses so she diminishes all four
other senses down to zero so their sense
of smell can be at its peak but she also
has like enhanced strengths and
different things like that but again a
lot of these things aren't really given
to us she said we just in it don't now
and has these different powers and
that's really about it now she's also a
prodigious fighter she can also see
slightly into the future and so she
knows the moves that people are going to
make before they make them now of course
this also leads directly into her her
motivation in the sense that she like
Arnim Zola believed
their son is dead and so remember Arnim
Zola inside Steve Rogers is a totally
different being than Arnim Zola the
robot they do not communicate they do
not talk they have no way of knowing the
other ones there so the best example I
can give is like from Harry Potter right
Voldemort one of the Horcruxes the The
Diary of Tom Riddle was able to act
totally separate in and of itself but
Voldemort didn't know about it he
couldn't talk to it he wasn't tell you
know telepathically aware of what was
going on it was just a totally separate
entity so again it's really kind of a
that's the best example that I can think
of off the top of my head you know
spur-of-the-moment but the fact remains
here that ultimately we end up finding
the frocks leading somewhat of a revolt
but not by choice what we end up finding
out is that armed Zola basically sent
his forces out across the landscape to
find Captain America now again this is
basically him alongside a jet black
going out to get revenge on Captain
America because in their mind
Captain America led to the death of
arnim zola's son and jet blacks brother
and so because of that the fight is
relatively short-lived in the sense that
we end up seeing them you know kind of
hold their own but the other half of
this is that Captain America inspired a
lot of these members of the frocks to
basically fight as best they can and so
while Captain America and Ian jump into
the fray Steve Rogers comes into direct
conflict with jet black now this is when
we get that little bit of an explanation
by Rick Remender in terms of what she's
capable of but again it's really only
situational it's not super complex it's
not super in-depth it's only really this
scenario where Steve Rogers doesn't
understand why she's so fast he doesn't
understand why she's able to predict his
moves before she before he makes them
but that's really it I mean there's not
a whole lot doing here the ability for
Steve Rogers to make his getaway comes
into play when we end up having Ian
making his presence known and Ian
basically showing himself to jet black
means that as far as she's aware now
he's very much alive and so what ends up
happening here is Captain America uses
the opportunity to basically grab in and
get out of there now of course this
comes after the conflict between Arnim
Zola and and Captain America himself but
again basically making his escape kind
of stumbling away the last action that
he takes here the fact that he has this
little Arnim Zola inside his body if the
last action that he takes here is to
basically grab a knife to essentially
gut himself and cut this thing directly
out of his insides and so it's kind of
gruesome it's kind of screwed up but
this shows us how ruthless Captain
America can be when it comes to really
achieving his goal but it also
shows us how Dark Dimension Z is that
he's really kind of being forced to
revert to some pretty base instincts to
some pretty based forms it's just meant
to show us that Steve Rogers is doing
what it takes in order to get out of
dimension Z proper okay so as we pick up
with the second half of the dimension Z
story for those of you guys who are
curious as to why it is that Sharon
Carter is old and all-new all-different
marvel this explains that and that's one
of the other reasons why I wanted to
cover this is because it's the little
tidbits that sort of kick off with this
story that end up leading us into
understanding all the different facets
of what's going on with all-new
all-different Captain America Steve
Rogers now of course again we'll get to
the whole Hydra stuff and all that once
we cover Avengers stand off and we'll
offer more of an explanation or at least
a more in context based explanation once
we get to that particular story you
don't make a lot more sense once we once
we get there but the fact remains
following the conflict between jet black
and Steve Rogers what is up happening
here is jet very much finds herself
romantically interested in Steve that's
one of the crazy things is offered here
what we're basically told is that with
the upbringing that she received from
her father
Arnim Zola he kept her very isolated
away from any possibility of romantic
interest with other people around her
now a lot of this was done because of
the fact that in the eyes of of Arnim
Zola romance is inherently a distraction
in the sense that it'll get in the way
of actual motivations and so because of
that in order to make sure that jet
black functioned at her peak capacity
there could be no distractions
there could be no romantic interest or
any things like that and indeed that's
how she reached the level that she's at
right now is by not having any romance
at anybody now in truth a lot of that
was because of the fact that the
creatures that surrounded her were just
grotesque as hell and so there was no
chance of her ever falling in love with
those things in the first place but the
fact remains here that with Steve Rogers
his combat prowess the fluid nature of
his movements the fact that he fights
with his heart and soul is intriguing to
jet because he's as much of a warrior as
she is so it's kind of like this romance
forged in the fires of battle kind of
situation it's a little screwed up but
it's also a little romantic to a degree
you know as one of those weird weird
little things but the fact remains steve
is very much on a mission to regain en
from the clutches of Arnim Zola the
problem with this is that Arnhem is
basically going to work on on Ian he's
going to work for the
as of trying to sway Ian to his side now
the way this initially kicks off is that
Arnhem basically beseeches Ian and says
hey look I'm your actual father I need
you very very much now in truth Arnhem
is just being very manipulative that's
all it is he's just manipulating his son
for the purpose of bringing him back
under his under his control now the
reason for that is because of the fact
that remember
Arnim Zola basically plays mind games
with the heroes that he goes against
specifically with Steve Rogers because
they've been enemies for quite so quite
so long with regards to how Arnim Zola
views Captain America I would say he
views him or he really knows him as well
as almost anybody in C Rogers personal
life after seeing how he fights the
scene that thinks he cares about and so
on and so forth and so by taking control
of his son he can in turn take control
of Steve Rogers now this is very Nazi
oriented and that was the nature of
Arnim Zola back in the day you know a
lot of those campaigns when he existed
under the Nazis before he eventually
defected and went over to Hydra it was
this whole idea that with the the Hitler
Youth for example you control the
parents by controlling the kids and so
by basically taking over the son of
Captain America he can sway Ian to his
side and then use Iain as a way to
defeat Captain America and that's
exactly what happens now what he does is
he basically uses brainwashing he
subjects Ian to non-stop images of
Captain America fighting but what he
does is he says ian is not the first
child that Captain America has taken and
used for his own purposes of course he
points to Bucky Barnes now the funny
thing about this is that Rick Remender
is kind of bringing in edy Brubaker's
retcons
as well as the public perception of
Bucky Barnes and what I mean is that in
the old Captain America comics from the
1940s you know going into the the late
1940s really kind of the early 1950s
Bucky Barnes was just the traditional
sidekick kid he was the hero or the the
sidekick who stumbled across Captain
America changing into his uniform and
was like I won't tell anybody your
secret if you make me your sidekick and
the two of them fought alongside forever
and then you know they were both kind of
captured the idea of a true Baker's
retcons came into play in a sense that
were we believed previously that Bucky
Barnes had just died in the explosion of
Baron Zemo as you know drone plane that
Bucky Barnes had actually been taken by
the Russians and turned into the Winter
Soldier but prior to that Bucky Barnes
was not just some kid on a military base
that came across Steve Rogers changing
into
Captain America uniform instead Bucky
Barnes had been trained in espionage had
been trained and stuffed had been
trained in in torture and all different
kinds of military tactics that would
allow him to gain the information that
he needed because Captain America was
not willing to torture because he wasn't
willing to kill Bucky Barnes was
assigned to him in order to serve as
part of the invaders but the public
perception was that Bucky Barnes was
just the sidekick and that's what Arnim
Zola Graf's he grabs the public
perception and then broadcast it to Ian
and says everybody thought that Bucky
Barnes was a sidekick but he was just a
kid the Captain America just took and
made a sidekick of his own again
manipulating Ian tricking Ian into
believing certain things and of course
this also coincides with Captain America
arriving you know to confront jet black
and of course this is where Jets
loyalties begin to be torn you know
where Ian officially is brainwashed
where he's inducted into the views of
Arnim Zola and basically becomes his
henchman jet black goes the opposite way
she begins to side with Captain America
and the reason why is because of the
fact that he basically tells her look at
everything that's going on around you
open your eyes like arnim zola's a bad
guy he's enslaving races that he's
created he's torturing them for
information you know he wants to conquer
all of reality and invade earth he is a
bad guy you have to see him for what he
is
and when you do then you'll know what
road to take what path to choose now
eventually she makes this makes this
decision when Steve Rogers saves the
life of one of the innocent frocks that
have been taken by autumn Zola for the
purpose of trying to create a new race
of soldiers trying to evolve them and
make a new race of super soldiers and so
because of the bravery demonstrated by
Captain America here jet black
ultimately sways to his side and
basically betrays her father to a degree
but Roberto royalties are torn she's
torn between her father the man who
raised her despite the failings that he
has and Captain America who she's in
love with so again it's really kind of
cool to see them going back and forth to
see them kind of kind of you know
missing and mashing but ultimately where
Steve Rogers begins the process of
making his way to Arnim Zola to
basically conquer him while jet black
makes her way towards freeing all the
other frocks that have been taken care
of taken prisoner we end up having Iain
jump into the fray and shooting Captain
America now again this is gonna be kind
of cool because this is Steve Rogers
trying to get his son back to his side
and on the surface ian does not
initially join him Ian basically says
look my name is Leopold it's not Ian at
the same time we also end up finding out
this entire Citadel this base of
operations is basically just an
interdimensional craft that will allow
Arnim Zola to move from this dimensions
Eve into the main Marvel Universe and
began the process of conquering earth
after amassing all these different you
know creatures that he's created as a
massive army of sources so again what is
up happening here is that while
jet-black is able to free a lot of these
members of the Fox Steve Rogers is able
to finally sway his son to his side now
the cool thing about this about what
Rick Remender is doing with this bit of
a story is it's basically kind of
harkening back to Bucky Barnes right I
mean for years and years and years Steve
Rogers just believed Bucky Barnes was
dead
Brubaker brought that back and said no
Bucky Barnes was alive but he was being
kept in stasis between missions by the
Russian KGB to carry out assassinations
on behalf of the Russian government and
so because of that when Steve Rogers
finally came to the realization that
Bucky Barnes was very much alive what it
ultimately meant was it see Rogers can
now bring Bucky Barnes back to sanity
now of course what this did is it
basically left Marvel with the ability
to create some really really cool
stories with Bucky Reed has kind of went
forward knowing his memories as the
Winter Soldier and having his memories
as a sidekick of Captain America and
kind of finding his own way in the
Marvel Universe eventually becoming the
man on the wall but the fact remains
here that this is that scenario for
Steve Rogers compounded by the fact that
he views Ian as his son he doesn't view
Ian as his adopted son he doesn't view
Ian as a surrogate son he views Ian as
his son and that's kind of the cool
thing here this is Rick Remender
bringing in the concept of like parents
who adopt kids right you know there are
parents out there who adopt kids and
that's their child it's no one else's
trial that's their child and they raise
that child as their own they teach that
child everything they believe to be
right and wrong you know that child
might as well be theirs in terms of a
biological sense it's not but it might
as well be because they're just as good
as their biological child with Captain
America it's the same way he views Ian
as his son he raised that child from
infancy up to where he is right now
and so he's not just fighting a foe he's
not just fighting Bucky Barnes as the
Winter Soldier and then using the Cosmic
Cube you know to help him kind of
jumpstart his memories what it is is
it's him
trying to bring his son back and
ultimately in this moment of beseeching
his son when he says I love you
Ian begins to sort of snap out of it Ian
begins to wake up and basically realizes
that Captain America really does care
about him and view him as a son
unfortunately none of it matters because
of the fact that Sharon Carter shoots
him in the neck she shoots him in the
neck and it is wild it really kind of
came out of nowhere now Sharon Carter
being here was initially just kind of
like what how in the world does she get
here well Rick Remender is nothing if
not a guy who knows how to tell a damn
good story and so because of this what
we end up finding out throughout the
entirety of his time here you know time
as it passes in dimension Z is much
faster than as it passes in the main
Marvel Universe now in truth this is
really just recomendar giving himself a
way out but we really kind of knew that
was gonna have to be the case right like
you couldn't ride a story about Captain
America trapped in dimension Z he
escapes and then 20 years have passed in
the real world honestly that just
wouldn't work we would have had to no
they would have had to be had to be some
kind of MacGuffin right like a cosmic he
would have to be used or he would have
to time travel or any number of other
things would have to be invoked in order
to set things back to rights but what
Sharon Carter says is look as soon as
you took off on that subway train and
things seemed wrong I follows you what
ended up happening is that while you
believe that you know a decade has
passed you know 15 years or somebody
that have passed in truth only 30
minutes have passed in the main Marvel
Universe so it's almost like he was gone
for the blink of an eye half an hour and
she's caught up with him now again this
allows Marvel to kind of bring Captain
America out of dimension Z as if no time
had passed at all and keep the existing
continuity and tact because remember
this is all really just kind of leading
up to the collapse of the multiverse is
all leading up to Secret Wars and it's
leading up to Captain America losing the
Super Soldier Serum in his battle with
iron nail and Sam Wilson taking up the
mantle and so because of this it's a
multi-faceted conflict on different
sides against Arnim Zola you have
jet-black free the different frocks and
then going against Arnim Zola raising an
army against him at the same time you
also have Sharon Carter and Steve Rogers
going against Arnim Zola proper now
ultimately Sharon Carter's able to pull
this off but only in the sense that she
basically has to detonate the entirety
of arnim zola's dimensional ship
whatever it is in order to basically
pull off his defeat the issue here
though is that in the process Captain
America and jet black are able to make
their escape back to the main Marvel
Universe but in the process Sharon
Carter is believed to have been caught
in the explosion and basically left
behind now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that again for
those of you guys who are going to be
getting in early I guess for those guys
who were picking up with Captain America
Steve Rogers from all-new all-different
marvel
Sharon Carter's old because of the fact
that she's been stuck in dimension Z all
this time now the reason why Captain
America didn't age is because he's got
the Super Soldier Serum he'll stay young
no matter where he is he could be in a
dimension where time travels 500 times
faster than it does in the main Marvel
Universe and he will age accordingly and
he'll still get older but he won't age
by 500 years he'll age by a fraction of
that okay so we officially are going to
begin I guess this is really more of a
prelude than anything else but this gets
us into the territory of the iron nail
which is a guy by the name of ranch in I
think it is he was a guy created by Rick
Remender but it's basically the
villainous responsible for stripping
Captain America of his Super Soldier
Serum and it's really cool because he's
basically the reason Steve Rogers
becomes an old man and it's really
really interesting kind of set the stage
for all-new all-different marvel
different things like that but though
the guys who read Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers infinity that
kind of stuff this is the reason why
that happened now something else that I
want to point out here and this is
something I haven't really brought up up
to this point if you were to go through
and you were to look up like Avengers
and New Avengers you were to look up
like the pre lewd to Secret Wars you
wanted to look up the events that led
into the collapse of the multiverse and
so on and so forth you had read through
Avengers and new Avengers and then
suddenly you would pick up a story
called eight months later what eight
months later was designed to do was
basically follow up all these individual
stories because remember Marvel still
had a ton of stories going on for
individual characters and teams when the
events of Secret Wars suddenly kicked
off you basically had last days and so
on and so forth and so what that man is
between the trade eight months later and
the story before it all this stuff with
Captain America took place all the
things with Black Widow and with be
Incredible Hulk and all that kind of
stuff all that took place and so it'll
be kind of interesting because what
we'll actually do is when we get to our
marvel cosmology we'll roll Captain
America into you know that playlist and
will actually stick it right between
these two
things eight months later and the story
that came before it so you guys will be
able to see it in chronological order
but I just kind of want to throw that
out but again Rick Remender is amazing
when it comes to how it is that he
writes Steve Rogers and what's so funny
about this is you can see the Rick
Romero Argos yeah you can really see the
inspiration from Rick Remender and the
writing of Nick Spencer with regards to
all-new all-different Captain America
and you know with regards to secret
Empire and all that kind of good stuff
because what we end up having here is
basically Steve Rogers after the events
of dimension Z when he advocates twelve
years inside of this other dimension for
time pass faster only to find out that
once he got back in the main Marvel
Universe only thirty minutes had passed
and so he experienced 12 years of living
he experienced what it was like to
basically take a child who was being
raised by a despot and then make that
child a superhero more or less teach
that child teach Ian everything he knew
about what it meant to stand up to do
the right thing but all of these lessons
that Steve Rogers passed on to his
adopted son came by way of the lessons
that were passed on to him from his
mother and that's the coolest thing is
because what Rick Remender gives us are
these really touching final moments and
it's really cool because as she tells
him these lessons actually teaches him
these things we also get this sort of
overrun where he's basically going
through surgery to get rid of the last
little tidbits of Arnim Zola that are
stuck inside of his body of course a lot
of this work is being done by Bruce
Banner and Hank Pym it's so cool to see
this because his mother says Steve
Rogers has been through so much and he
has I mean as a child he lived through
the Great Depression he saw what it was
to live in abject poverty he experienced
a father who abused his mother you know
and right now he's basically seeing his
mother dying and so because of that she
basically says look the road that you've
taken the path that that that life has
put you on has the ability to send you
in two different directions you are
coming up on a fork in the road when the
time comes that I leave this world you
will be at a fork and you can go left
and become a horrible human being the
world is terrible the world's bad just
become this really cynical person that's
just filled with anger and negativity or
you can go right and become every bit of
the man that I know you are you can
become optimistic and she passes these
things on to him she says people are
optimistic people try to do the right
thing if given the choice between right
and wrong people will do right but the
funny thing about this
we can also kind of attribute this to
like an archaic method of thinking right
a cynical person would say no no no no
that's how things used to be but people
don't don't think like that anymore and
they don't talk like that anymore
but then again that's just a reflection
of what it is that we happen to see or
what we choose to see with regards to
what it is in his mother saying here in
their heart of hearts when it comes down
to it when you strip past all the layers
when you get past all the struggle and
strife people are inherently good and
she says no matter what happens no
matter what happens to you no matter
what what roads what events that you see
after this you always have to do the
right thing you always have to be the
right guy you have to make the decisions
that you think are best you have to
fight on behalf of what you think is
right but these are very general terms
these are very general ideas do the
right thing
fight for the right cause stand up for
those who cannot stand up for themselves
but this is all just a reflection of
Captain America as we traditionally see
him and you know to kind of bring in
secret Empire for a second because this
is really all kind of leading up to that
so I think we can have this bit of a
discussion bringing in secret Empire for
a second that's what makes this so cool
and that's what makes secret Empire so
cool is because we think of Captain
America and he does the right thing he
always fights the good fight he stands
up for people that can't help themselves
all the while championing the American
flag what if he did all those things but
instead of an American flag he had a
hydro flag well then suddenly it changes
everything
because now he's not fighting for
American ideals he's fighting for Hydra
ideals and Hydra ideals are different
from American ideals but it's also a
reflection of society and that's really
what Nick Spencer is doing with secret
Empire he's basically criticizing modern
society he's criticizing how things
function at the moment but in the realm
of Marvel Comics secret Empire was just
the most logical outcome of the events
that have transpired so far I mean with
Captain America being a Hydra agent and
looking around and just kind of biding
his time waiting for a chance to take
over the world he wakes up one morning
only to find out that Thanos had decided
to invade the planet Earth why because
of the fact that he's trying to wipe out
all of his offspring across the universe
and one of them just happens to be on
earth this leads to a war with the
Inhumans blackbolt absolutely freaks out
in a state of panic detonates the
Terrigen bomb which begins spreading the
myths all across the planet Earth these
myths just happened to be deadly to
mutants and when the mutants as the
Inhumans to stop the Inhumans say no
because our numbers are growing
like us asking you to stop having
mutants that are born to sit we
eliminate mutants in their entirety this
leads to a war between the Inhumans and
the mutants but during this time and
inhuman is subtly warned that has the
ability to supposedly see into the
future Carol Danvers takes it as an
absolute truth this leads to a conflict
between her and Tony Stark setting off
the second Civil War all the while
Captain America is just watching the
events unfold and watching the superhero
community become more and more fractured
the Avengers are going in there fighting
various villains there's collateral
damage people are completely displaced
when their homes are destroyed and the
Avengers just leave allowing damage
control Incorporated to take over Kamala
Khan and Miles Morales and a handful of
others get tired of seeing that so they
branched off from the Avengers they form
their own faction called the champions
Captain America looks around and sees
the superhero community society itself
is more and more fractured Sam Wilson is
the new Captain America and people don't
like it because it's different from what
they're used to and as a result humanity
within the realm of the Marvel Universe
starts tweeting out things like hashtag
not my captain if society itself became
as fractured as it did over something as
nonsensical as who it is is wearing
Captain America shield
if superheroes can't get along if
they're waging war against one another
if Captain America sits down and says
society is inherently broken and I as
Captain America am a protector of
society then the only option I have here
is to protect society from itself and
that ultimately leads to him stepping in
initiating all these different plans
becoming director of shield and
dominating the entirety of the United
States setting his sights on the rest of
the world it's an amazing series of
events that all led up to the singular
instance of Captain America ruling
everything now of course again this all
really predates that kind of getting
back into this story a little bit
because we kind of got off it got off on
a bit of a tangent this predates all
that this is still the Captain America
that you guys know and love when you
think of Steve Rogers but the cool thing
here is that this all really just kind
of leads to that final moment it leads
to that grandiose scenario of Captain
America being plant being appointed as
director of shield and gaining absolute
power over the US military taking
control of the United States during the
events of secret Empire number zero now
what we're gonna do here is we're
actually gonna jump back a little bit to
1968 and the reason why is because we're
actually going to join a guy by the name
of
now ranch in is effectively a guy who
was formerly a SHIELD agent that's kind
of the crazy thing here is because of
the fact that we end up seeing him just
sort of approaching this dragon that
looks an awful lot like Fin Fang Foom
but the result here is that a bargain is
more or less struck now we're not given
a whole lot of information about this
dragon all we're really told here is
that this thing basically has the
ability to in the imbue is some measure
of power we don't know what that means
we don't really know what it makes him
capable of and at least not ride off the
bat what we do instead is we actually
end up jumping forward a little bit to
1969 by about a year and we basically
have Shen being held captive by dum-dum
Dugan and Nick Fury now this is when we
learned most of the backstory about his
character that he was basically one of
the absolute best shield agents that
were out there but he was assigned the
task of infiltrating communist China
during its rise to power and see if
there was basically a way to topple
Chairman Mao but what this ended up
doing is it basically led to Shen
becoming corrupted by the power that he
possessed as he rose through the ranks
eventually being ousted by Chairman Mao
himself which led to shin and you know
encountering this dragon in the first
place and so what this does is it
basically shows us this is how Nick Fury
and this is how dum-dum Dugan lose their
infinity serum now this is something
that's interesting because not a lot of
people know about this the infinity
serum is what it is that allowed Nick
theory to stay so young for such a
length of time this of course all really
kind of goes back into the idea of Nick
Fury and his Howling Commandos back in
the 1960s when what were first
introduced Nick Fury in his Howling
Commandos they're basically just a world
war 2 team but the cool thing is that
their history delved into a lot of
different things for example they were
tasked with finding dr. Abraham Erskine
and bringing him to the United States
Abraham Erskine of course being the man
who is responsible for making Steve
Rogers into Captain America so again
when Nick Fury's Howling Commandos had a
lot of hands at a lot of different
events that had taken place over the
course of Marvel Comics but along the
way they had discovered an infinity
formula that if ingested would basically
slow the aging process and I don't know
exactly what the ratio is but for the
sake of this discussion we'll say you
know 10 or I guess one for every 10 so
for every every 10 years the pass they
only ever paged about like one year
that's just kind of throwing a random
number out there I don't think we're
ever actually given an exact number but
it gives you an idea of how slow they
aged but the fact remains that in the
middle of this interrogation process a
ranch in basically attacks Nick Fury and
dum-dum Dugan and strips them of their
infinity formula now this is basically
Rick Remender setting up the events of
the conflict between Ranchin and Captain
America himself where ranch is
eventually going by the name the iron
nail and ends up stripping Steve Rogers
of his Super Soldier Serum but again
it's a really really cool bit of
storytelling here and the reason why is
because of the fact that after Reed
awning one of his shield outfits and
scheana's basically tracked down by
Bucky Barnes now Bucky Barnes had been
assigned to basically kill shin just my
virtue of his role as part of the Winter
Soldier under the control of the
Russians and it was a different set of
events that was taking place in bitter
March but the idea here is that this
also coincides with a point in time when
Nick Fury did not know who Bucky Barnes
is and so again for those of you guys
who read IDI Brubaker's run that saw the
return of Bucky Barnes to Marvel Comics
when Nick Fury was the one who was
giving Steve Rogers all this information
on the Winter Soldier the idea that it
might be Bucky Barnes this series of
events right here is what set the stage
for Nick Fury to launch that
investigation in the first place
eventually leading up to Eddie
Brubaker's run and the revelation that
Bucky Barnes was still alive at least as
far as Captain America knew so again a
lot of history's being made in this
little bit of a story a model a lot of
information is kind of being thrown at
us and so it was really kind of cool to
see how all the dots connect and how it
all really just kind of comes together
but what are the last little tidbits
that we end up picking up here is the
concept of weapon - now we have a video
that I've already made on a history of
Weapon X of weapons plus all that kind
of stuff so you guys can basically check
that video out you'll find it down in
the description but weapon - it was
basically shields response to weapons
Plus that a program that basically set
the stage for the introduction of
Wolverine Wade Wilson becoming Deadpool
weapons Plus was basically the one that
set all that stuff up you know phantom X
and all that kind of good stuff but the
fact remains that behind this door is
actually a guy by the name of dr. mind
bubble and we'll learn a little bit more
about him later on in terms of the role
that he plays here but at this point we
actually kind of jumped back to the
modern day and what we end up finding
out is between the time that that that
Shin escaped and adopted the mantle of
iron nail up into the modern day he's
essentially operating out of the Great
Wall of China and
he's doing is he's going through to all
the wealthiest people around China and
basically taking them prisoner and
forcing them to work in camps for the
purpose of allowing him to find mines or
go through all the mines all I kind of
stuff whatever resources happened to be
there in addition to his own plans but
in truth this is Rick Remender actually
showing us a pretty interesting
situation on the surface we would look
at iron nail and say he's a bad guy he's
doing bad things
is he really because those individuals
who basis we made their money by using
the working class for their own ends and
then disposing of them when they were of
no more use he's actually not the worst
person ever at least some individuals
would say that not only that it's also
Rick Remender kind of poking fun at this
idea of money and how very you know how
worthless it is for example these guys
that are being brought here are
billionaires they're people with so much
money but for all the money that they
have what good does it do them they're
still working in these case just like
everybody else they're being made the
work to the point that they die just
like everybody else where's their
billions of dollars where's their cars
where's their houses how is any of that
going to protect them when it all came
down to it who they were as people was
the only thing they had and that wasn't
enough to do them any help and so again
it's really kind of this idea that these
extremely wealthy individuals kind of
surrounded themselves with all the
resources in the world only to find out
to those resources meant absolutely
nothing now this is when we get into the
idea I guess really a little bit of a
follow up with regards to to Captain
America and the reason why is because of
the fact that remember following his
escape from Dimension Z he was also
joined with jet black basically the
daughter of Arnim Zola who had been
specifically engineered for the purpose
of being somebody able to engage in
combat but what we also find out is that
a deal was struck between Steve Rogers
and jet black the jet black was
inevitably going to be brought in by
shield now of course she's currently
being interrogated by Nick Fury jr. and
aside track for a second there was an
interview that Tom Brevoort did you know
one of the the I think the
vice-president of something over a
marvel there was an interview that he
did with with I want to say it was
Newsarama or something like that and
they were talking about the character of
Nick Fury jr. basically the black son of
Nick Fury senior who's a white guy and
when the question was asked how do you
reconcile those two things and why is
that version of Nick Fury here the
answer was what we know we just need
more african-american representation and
comic books which didn't really make a
whole lot of sense because you basically
had Samuel Jackson Nick Fury in the
Ultimate Universe now the
could be drawn here that the ultimate
universe was far less popular than the
main Marvel Universe in which case the
question has to be asked why not just
bring that version of Nick Fury over but
the fact remains here that's really the
only reason why his characters here is
because of the fact that there needed to
be more african-american representation
and Marvel according to the Marvel brass
themself so again he doesn't really have
any intrinsic value here he's really
just here for the sake of diversity
which is really kind of interesting but
the fact remains here that with Steve
Rogers showing up and basically removing
jet black from the equation this is when
we learned that the bargain that was
struck between the two of them was the
idea that jet black would not reveal any
of the information about Ian and Steve
Rogers would basically help her cope
with how to get past or how to live in a
normal life in the main Marvel Universe
and so what we end up finding out here
is that Steve Rogers feels very out of
time he feel feels very displaced
following the time he spent in dimension
Z raising Ian only to basically realize
that Ian was killed accidentally by
Sharon Carter and Sharon Carter herself
presumably died in the events of
dimension Z and so because of that Steve
Rogers basically feels like there's
nothing here for him now this is really
kind of Rick Remender going back and
co-opting a lot of the stuff that we saw
when Captain America first showed up in
the 1960s it really first came back and
Avengers number four and the reason why
is because of the fact that back in the
1950s when Captain America was first
brought back by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
the stories of the time were designed to
be upbeat you would really never see
anything like what we're seeing now back
in their method of storytelling Stan Lee
their various interviews always stated
that he liked to keep things upbeat he
liked to keep things happy relatively
cheerful you know he didn't want comics
to be somewhat of a downer or in a lot
of ways a reflection of real life the
only real measure of reflection that
came in Stan Lee's early writings was
how people interacted with one another
and how teenagers were depicted and
different things like that but with this
particular bit of storytelling Ruper
mandir is very much taking the opposite
approach that you know Steve Rogers
feels very much like he did when he was
thought out during the events of
Avengers number four when he was saved
by the Avengers themselves but with
Sharon Carter being gone with his son
basically being gone there's no reason
for him to be here he feels like there's
no purpose for him in this world and so
it was really kind of cool to see a man
that's just struggling and we never
really see Captain America this way
Captain America is always the confident
guy he's always the guy on the
lines first in last out neo because of
that is always one of the most
interesting scenarios to see him when
he's so confident when he's so strong
and then suddenly so emotional
effectively having a breakdown in front
of Sam Wilson and so again what this
does is it basically coincides with the
character of nuke now Frank Simpson was
one of the byproducts of the weapon plus
event campaign that basically led to two
James Howlett becoming Wolverine and
Wade Wilson becoming Deadpool but the
difference here is that Frank Simpson
basically ingest pills that amp him up
they get him prepped and excited for war
the idea here though is that somebody is
basically issuing him orders
somebody's basically telling him you
need to go into these various
territories that the United States has
had wars in and finished those guys off
and because Frank Simpson is so gung-ho
because he's so extreme this is exactly
what he's doing he's going around to
different territories where the US had
conflicts and essentially had to pull
out because they more or less lost he's
going through and just killing everybody
that he sees spraying them all down with
bullets and then planting American flags
and Frank Simpsons mind as insane as he
is he's basically winning the war that
America lost in that particular area now
the reason why this is so significant is
because of the fact that the press has
not gotten wind of what it is that's
going on but if the media finds out that
a guy with an American flag tattoo on
his face is running amok in countries
where the United States had previously
lost conflicts killing everybody there
and then planting American flags is
going to create an international
incident and so because of that she'll
basically sends in Steve Rogers and Sam
Wilson highly under the radar and has
them take out Frank Simpson now this is
kind of interesting because with the
character of nuke and a lot of ways he
looks up to Captain America and he's not
the only one we know the Punisher for
example enlisted in the Vietnam War
because he wanted to be Captain America
and this is really Rick Remender kind of
pointing at the legacy that was made by
Steve Rogers because he was such an
iconic character because in the eyes of
a lot of people he was America
personified fighting against the Axis
powers the legacy that he created stands
the test of time as one of the most
significant legacies in the history of
Marvel Comics this also coincides with
the idea that in the modern day Captain
America is the de facto leader of the
Avengers his word
almost universally accepted as law you
can have the entirety of the Avengers
you can have 100 members of the Avengers
in a room arguing over what stuff they
should take next and some campaign
that's going on somewhere Captain
America will stand up he will speak
everybody will stop they will listen and
when he says this is what we're doing
that's what will get done and so it's
really a cool thing to see his character
depicted in this manner and so to
basically have you know frankly Frank
Simpson saying look I'm trying to
respect our boys you know I'm trying to
respect our guys in the military I'm
trying to win the war that they lost I'm
trying to make America great again you
know someone on those lines what it
basically does is it leads to the idea
the Frank Simpson is essentially beyond
hope beyond redemption and is
effectively insane and that's the nature
of his character he's just a crazy guy
and so because of this we end up having
him subdued by Captain America and by
Sam Wilson and then taken by shield and
placed in custody but what we end up
finding out here is that this has all
been a part of the plan of iron nail and
the reason why is because of the fact
that shin has been giving or he's the
one that was giving a nuke all the
information that he needed he was the
one that was sending nuke on all these
different campaigns and the one having
him interact with all this stuff
knowing that shield was another lis
going to arrest him and was going to
take him into custody the reason why he
did that is because an explosive had
been planted inside of nuke and living
up to his namesake chin detonates the
explosive effectively sending shield
into a state of disarray after which he
initiates his second phase which is to
basically free dr. mind bubble the guy
who was responsible for launching the
weapons - program and the guy that has
the ability to effectively ensnare
people in little pockets of reality if
he so wishes by trapping them inside one
of his bubbles it's really crazy the
events that are getting ready to go down
are absolutely insane but again all this
is going to lead into Steve Rogers
losing his Super Soldier Serum all this
is going to lead into him becoming an
old man setting the stage for Sam Wilson
to become the new Captain America
so getting into the iron nail the story
when Steve Rogers loses the Super
Soldier Serum this is super cool like
it's definitely one of my Captain
America my favorite Captain America
stories because it just seems like a
natural progression right I mean we knew
as the reader that like a time will come
when Steve Rogers will just stop being
Captain America and it makes sense I
mean after a while you can only ever
tell so many stories there's only so
many times where you can read about
Steve Rogers running into the
battlefield Avengers are simple freedom
like there's only so many times before
us like okay let's get something a
little bit new but the idea here was
that witness initially dropped it was
very divisive in the community people
absolutely began to freak out you know
Captain America purists lost their minds
they could not imagine anybody besides
Steve Rogers playing the role of Captain
America they were just kind of trapped
in that mindset at the same time you had
people who wanted to see Captain America
kind of just remain the hero that they
always envisioned they weren't really
locked into the character but for them
it's just Steve Rogers was always
Captain America and so it created kind
of like one of those interesting
scenarios but for me I always loved this
I always loved this story I loved the
idea of simply seeing somebody else
carry the mantle even if it was only
gonna be for a temporary amount of time
or even if it was permanent I always
thought it would be kind of cool and in
truth I loved what Hickman did with with
Captain America and vendors and New
Avengers where he's just like this old
man cynical and angry at the world and
just like running shield trying to get
revenge on the Illuminati it was kind of
cool it was it was really an interesting
concept but again what we also get is
this depiction of what it is that dr.
mind a bubble does in the sense that
remember in the last video we talked
about how nuke was just this crazy
military guy he was basically trying to
win wars that had long since been over
us we was going into international
territories you're going into other
countries into sovereign states shooting
their people out planting American flags
and it threatened to create an
international incident and so the result
was that he was basically captured by
Captain America and Sam Wilson as Falcon
and then kept prisoner on a shield
Helicarrier only for us to find out that
he was being used by the iron nail a
bomb was put inside of him and he was
detonated resulting in the deaths of
some one hundred and sixty some odd you
know shield agents the destruction of
the Helicarrier and nuke himself and so
again what doctor Mind bubble does or at
least what what this little tidbit does
is it basically picks up with Frank
Simpson having single-handedly won the
war and that's really what his dream is
and that
doctor mind bubble works he has the
ability to manipulate reality around
individuals but only insofar that he
traps their minds inside of a reality
bubble so he's not like Franklin
Richards are like molecule man or
anything like that
he can't inherently alter reality itself
he somebody just kind of creates an
illusion inside the mind of the people
who were trapped in its bubbles and then
they believe it to be an absolute truth
and so because of this this is really
just designed to by mind bubble to
essentially allow Frank Simpson to
experience the the passing of a process
without really suffering or struggling
now in truth mean the guy's got a giant
hole in his chest so I guess it kind of
works but the fact remains here that we
also have mine bubble encountering ranch
in now keep him on ranch in the iron
nail had been the hidden hand behind all
of this he it had been on this campaign
to take down shield for years and years
and years and years and again a lot of
this is rooted in the fact that he felt
betrayed by shield in the sense that he
was an agent at one point long line he
was assigned to infiltrate Communist
China he eventually became this kind of
corrupted guy by having the shine of the
Shaolin scientist squad as Shaolin
scientist squad there we go was
ultimately you know kind of OWL stood by
Mao himself and then eventually
recaptured by shield again and so
because of that you know he'd
essentially lost his mind he'd kind of
gone drunk with coward and so the result
was that he's basically waging a war
against shield and trying to bring down
shield in its entirety now in truth this
is kind of a reflection of the larger
picture the shield is only one facet for
a ranch in it's really more of taking
down the establishment taking down all
these various individuals and we see
this play out when we end up having you
know Captain America and jet black again
the kind of you know dimensional
displaced daughter of Arnim Zola walking
side by side now the cool thing about
this is keep in mind the Rick Remender
is not teasing any sort of romance here
I mean he's not really saying you know
well jet-black him and Steve Rogers they
might become something it's not really
gonna work that way
in truth jet black its battle-hardened
she views the world wildly different
than Steve Rogers does she's ruthless
she's like look there are two types of
people in this world there's criminals
and there's people who were not
criminals criminals should die and
that's the end of that she's very
Punisher like in terms of how she
functions and in terms of what she does
whereas Captain America's a lot more
lenient everyone deserves a second
chance and that kind of a thing and so
the reason why this this sort of moral
quandary plays out is because they
basically end up you know as they're
walking along they end up running into a
guy who's effectively one of these you
know bigshot Wall Street bankers you
know who's just kind of pissed off
because
getting out enough bad loans and not
making him enough money and so on and so
forth but the Shaolin scientist squad
intervenes with the intention of
whisking this guy away and that's what
ranch hands been doing he's been sending
a scientists squad out into the world
and then capturing those individuals who
prey on others now it's not just bankers
it's you know like the wealthy elite
different things like that and that's
the war that he's been waging and that's
really kind of the moral quandary that's
being asked here you know like with Wall
Street bankers and different things like
that you know who's really at fault here
the person who issued the loan or the
person who signed their name on the
dotted line of the loan they knew they
couldn't afford that's why I create
scared of a funny scenario and there's
only really so much you can do if like
after the the mortgage crisis in 2008 an
army vigilantes had walked into wall
street and started carrying off all
these Wall Street bankers people
probably wouldn't have batted an eye
they probably would have said yeah man
they deserve it but then if they said ok
face-to is now to also take away those
people who sign their names on the
dotted lines of homes they couldn't
afford
well then suddenly people would start
freaking out and there will be excuses
galore well I didn't know all that kind
of good stuff and so because of that it
creates kind of this interesting
scenario the fact remains here that this
is tried-and-true Steve Rogers at the
end of the day despite the fact that
this guy is effectively a corporate
criminal despite the fact that this guy
is doing some pretty heinous things he
hasn't broken any literal laws yet he
hasn't actually broken a particular law
instead he's just a really shady Wall
Street guy and so Captain America is
beholden to the law and the law only and
that's the way its character always
functioned as a sense that he always
went against individuals who violated
the law Captain America was beholden to
the law itself he wasn't beholden to a
government he wasn't beholden to the
average person he was beholden to the
law end of freedom if flaws began to
encroach on freedom then he would in
turn battle against those laws in battle
on the side of freedom and so because of
those things he was very much a
patriotic character he was very much a
guy that there was a reflection of
average and normal society the funny
thing about this is that we end up
having the Shaolin scientist squat
basically just kind of like whisk away
you know more or less teleport when the
battle is over and Steve Rogers is
really just kind of left to allow this
guy to be taken by the cops you know to
be taken for for treatment and so on and
so forth
so again Steve Rogers himself is really
facing this moral quandary because he
looks around and says look man you're a
shady banker guy like the world would
legitimately be better off without you
if you just vanished you know if these
guys are taking you away and you were
working in some cave the
world would not mourn you the world
would not miss you there's nothing in
your life of any significance and so
we'd be fine without you you know but at
the end of the day he is beholden to the
law he's beholden to freedom he's
beholden to the idea that people who
commit crimes or do bad things should be
held accountable for that within the
confines of the law and that's really
kind of the nature that that's that's
the knife's edge the Captain America
walks because of all those all he would
ever really take and this is an argument
that he's made time and time again this
is an argument that's been made in
Marvel Comics time and time again
especially during the first Civil War
all his takes is making it acceptable
one time all it takes is for someone to
come along and say yeah that person did
something bad but the problem is if
there was a trial they would probably
get away with it let's just mix the
trial and just take him out in the
public square and shoot them let's just
do that because then we don't have to
worry about it and sure it would be more
efficient executing people for their
crimes statistically speaking does not
prevent people from committing crimes
it's not a deterrent but it does prevent
repeat offenders a person can't commit a
crime again if they're dead and so
because of that it'd be so much easier
and it would certainly smooth the
process out if people were just executed
on the spot for the concert they commit
but if you do that once then you can do
it twice and if you can do it twice you
can do it three times and then four
times or five times and suddenly it
becomes a societal standard structure
organization society itself breaks down
on a fundamental level and it's nothing
but the Wild West it's just a bunch of
crazy people running around with guns
shooting each other up because one guy
has something another guy wants and so
because of that in order to maintain
structure in order to maintain order
rules have to be imposed right wrong or
otherwise they are there and Captain
America fights on behalf of those so
long as they do not encroach on people's
freedom and so again it makes a really
cool scenario when it comes to his
character how he functions and how he
exists and so what we end up finding out
here is that in the aftermath of the
destruction of this Helicarrier we
essentially have you know Steve Rogers
basically showing up after the heist of
Maria Hill and she of course informs him
their weapons - is basically free and
that weapon - again basically dr. bind a
bubble was created to be a deterrent for
Steve Rogers for Wolverine for all those
different guys it was shields answer to
weapon Plus and so because of that jet
also uses her Omni senses her ability to
push any one of her senses to the to the
infinite peak and simply you know use
her sight to realize that neo Sam Wilson
is still alive which of course they end
up rescuing him but again
roll of dr. mine bubble begins to come
into play when we have a Nick Fury jr.
who has been taken by mine bubble and
while he believes while he sees inside
this illusion that he's basically
tracking down Hydra that hydras trying
to access something called a gun dear
ultimately this is really just mine
bubble using Nick theory to activate the
machinery itself now we'll actually find
out what that is and is and is really
really cool but this is when we
basically get this whole exposition on
what it is that doctor mind a bubble is
about of course we have Captain America
and we have Falcon trying to track down
Nick Fury as well as Mind bubble and so
on but we end up finding out from at
least from what they're told by Maria
Hill that initially when weapons class
was first launched with weapon zero with
Captain America Steve Rogers and project
rebirth and when the weapons Plus
project was turned into weapon one and
weapon two eleven three going all the
way up to weapons ten or weapons X with
Wolverine and then I'm actually going
into Deadpool and then so on and so
forth that shield realized that if super
soldiers were being cranked out and this
kind of variation and in these extremes
shield would need a countermeasure the
problem with this was that the sky horse
Littleton the one who was leaving the
project could not find any legit
volunteers after he had basically taken
LSD and merged it with the Super Soldier
Serum now the answer is not given to us
in terms of how he was able to locate
the Super Soldier Serum because keep in
mind that's the whole core of Captain
America dr. Abraham Erskine formed the
Super Soldier Serum the Super Soldier
Serum was originally intended to be a
deterrent against the expansion of
mutants in the Marvel Universe the
result is that you know following the
creation of Captain America Abraham
Erskine was killed by the Germans and
the secret of the Super Soldier Serum
was lost with him weapons we know two
three four five six going all the way up
to Wolverine and Deadpool those were all
basically attempts to either duplicate
the Super Soldier Serum or create
something wholly different so because
that we don't know how you know it is
that horse Lyttleton god the Super
Soldier Serum if it's even the legit
serum itself it could just be a spin-off
because there were no volunteers he
basically used it on himself and what it
did is it gave him the ability to create
these mind-altering bubbles that are
composed of literal LSD and Super
Soldier serum and then imposed those
bubbles on other people forces them to
see whatever it is that's inside there
now again horizontal Tim does not
control what people see inside that
bubble the bubbles are basically just
emitted from his mind and sort of thrown
out there and that's really about it I
mean the the structure is created by him
the environment is created by him what
in terms of how people experience things
in terms of those individuals who talk
to them or s does not have control of
that you know in the case of McPhee for
example it's just here is a dream where
Nik theory is helping to track down
Hydra and helping to defeat Hydra and
then whatever goes on inside that dream
is basically up to Nick Fury himself in
terms of how his mind construes it but
the fact remains here that with Horace
Milton behind the wheel and with iron
nail continuing to control everything
behind the scenes this ultimately leads
to a direct conflict between these two
shield hell occurs they literally just
crash into one another now of course
Captain America is doing what he can to
face off against these various guys to
try to bring this Helicarrier down in
this entirety but the fact remains that
with these two shield Helicarrier is
being forced to crash with all of this
happening under the control of mind
bubble himself it inevitably leads to a
conflict directly between Captain
America and iron nail now this is
effectively when Captain America begins
to lose the Super Soldier Serum and the
reason why is because of the fact that
remember ranch n basically has the
ability to emit these tendrils that will
absorb energies out of out of people
it'll basically absorb what it is that
makes them who they are they're a life
force or something along those lines but
even then it's not explicitly explained
it's really more like a plot device than
anything else we don't know for example
if iron nail would be able to attack
Kitty Pryde and then like absorb her X
gene we don't know if he would be able
to do things like that he probably
wouldn't the only indication we have of
what he can do is when he basically
absorbed the Infinity formula the
formula made Nick Fury and dum-dum Dugan
young when he absorbed that serum out of
them and the Nick Fury and dum-dum Dugan
grew really old really fast that's the
only indication of what it is that he
can do and even Captain America makes
that comment he doesn't know what nail
can do all he knows is that iron nail is
dangerous and somebody that needs to be
dealt with now this is kind of Rick
Remender playing on the nature of
Captain America right I mean Captain
America isn't the sharpest tool in the
shed I mean he's smart but he's really
more of like let's form a plan somebody
else give me the intelligence that I
need and then what I have that
intelligence then we'll form a plan on
what it is that we should do I mean it's
very indicative of what you would expect
from a leader a leader doesn't have to
know everything a leader just needs to
be able to surround himself with
effective people who know their
information so that way he can play the
role of consolidating all that
information bringing it together and
making it a cohesive plan that's why
Captain America was always a leader of
the Avengers but that's why people like
Iron Man are so essential because they
always
had an intrinsic ball to play you had
Tony Stark yet Hank Pym you know some of
the smartest people
he always had a Rain guy that's part of
the Avengers so that you would have that
intelligence aspect and Captain America
could use that noir to form his own
plans and so again in the midst of this
conflict it's exactly if you would
expect mine bubble arrives and traps
Captain America inside one of these
bubbles and this is when we basically
learn the hearts desire of Steve Rogers
what it is that he wants above all else
he is surrounded by friends he does have
jet black he doesn't have Nick Fury you
know Bucky Barnes is there it's really
this idea of hey man you made it out
alive and you saved all of us you know
it's so great that you pulled this off
the world is celebrating what it is that
you've done there's parades all that
kind of good stuff but it's also the
arrival or I guess the fact that ian is
still alive his son who's you know
basically dead as well as Sharon Carter
who's still alive who's effectively been
discovered and so because of that um
this is really kind of like the perfect
life of Steve Rogers the parade is a
reflection of what we would have
expected to see because had Captain
America not been frozen during World War
two when the conflict was over this is
what he would have seen at home he would
have seen parades streamers celebration
all that kind of good stuff he would
have seen all of that at the same time
with regards to Sharon Carter and Ian is
basically him having a family he's a
husband and he's a father and so because
that his life is basically complete he's
saved the superhero community and he's
got a family of his own this is really
what it is that he wants the most but in
the end he can't bring himself to accept
it because in his mind it's too perfect
now this is kind of interesting because
with Captain America we always kind of
looked at him we always kind of looked
at Steve Rogers and said okay this is a
guy who is a reflection of an archaic
time this is a guy who is a reflection
of an age when things were a little more
pure naive perhaps but it's not a
reflection of the modern day it's just
not how things are people don't don't
talk to each other the way they used to
they don't you know engage the kind of
things the way they used to and there's
all different kinds of argument you're
gonna strap with extrapolate for that
but the fact remains here that with
Steve Rogers himself looking out on this
and saying there's no possible way then
I could be living in a world that's
perfect the world doesn't exist this way
anymore
there's they don't do parades when wars
are won you know they don't do things
like that if this is the world then this
is not the real world this is not my
world
to have my wife or haven't have my
future wife back to have my son back to
a saved all the superheroes it doesn't
work that way the missions over we get
debriefed and then we get
on the next mission that's just how it
functions that's just how it goes
there's a million reasons for why this
world can't be real and so of course
Steve Rogers does the only one thing you
can do when it comes to escaping a mind
bubble he basically commits suicide and
that indeed is the only way to get out
of a mind bubble when you're trapped in
one you basically have to kill yourself
but this is why it's so dangerous is
because if the world around you shifts
and you believe is legitimately real and
you don't have the ability to
distinguish between what's real and
what's false then it's like putting a
gun in the hand of a schizophrenic is
the world that they're living in with a
gun real or is the world without the gun
real which one is true and which one is
false and so that's the crazy situation
it's because if you weren't able to tell
the difference you could be standing in
the real world out of the effects of a
mind bone and people are telling you no
no no do not pull that trigger you're
you're in the real world but to you
you're not in the real world you're in
the mind bubble the gun goes to the side
of your head that your gets pulled and
you are dead that's it there's no coming
back
and so because that that's what makes
dr. mind bubbles so dangerous is because
the shift between real and false could
take place and you would just never know
the fact remains here that was Steve
Rogers escaping this leads directly into
a conflict between himself and iron nail
yet again you know this battle between
the two of them now of course you know
mine bubble is more or less you know
incapacitated when Steve Rogers throws
his shield at mine bubbles head blocked
the access port where the bubbles come
out from and the result is that his mind
just starts filling up with all of his
own dreams and he really kind of goes
crazy and that's the end of that but we
also end up finding out that this gun
you're this device that they've
basically access is a Gundam is a giant
gundam no it's actually just a giant
machine really just kind of like a giant
robot which I guess it is a Gundam but
it's a weapon that shield had created
it's a weapon shielded created for the
purpose of of deterring and battling
against a massive threat now it's not
being used for the purpose of light you
know incapacitating the Hulk because
truth be told depending on how strong
this machinery is despite how big it is
the Hulk could probably still tear it
apart so it doesn't really matter on
that kind of scale the idea is that it's
really just another weapon created by
shield and so the result is that we're
you know this is basically being
accessed by iron nail and it's going to
be used for the intention of just kind
of obliterating you know society as a
whole and then sort of restructuring
everything under iron nail himself the
battle between Captain America and
brancion ultimately leads to Steve
Rogers you know having to go to the
central access core throwing a shield
basically destroying the core thereby
destroy
the robot and in the process while he is
able to get his shield off he's impaled
by these tendrils which begins draining
out the Super Soldier Serum from his
body and the result is that once it's
all said and done Ranch Inn is
effectively defeated and then we
basically have old man Steve Rogers he's
now lost his Super Soldier Serum and
that's effectively the end of him
and so what this does is it sets the
stage for a story called The Tomorrow
Soldier which will begin the process of
bringing in Sam Wilson as the new
Captain America in all-new all-different
Captain America okay Rob core I'm in a
weird situation and Benny wouldn't help
me out well he would but he wouldn't um
it's one of those funny things I do not
have a distinct branding unto my name
outside of you know with regards to like
stories and stuff you know I explain
things explaining stuff so like the
Infinity Gauntlet glove explained that
Cosmic Cube explained like I have those
kind of things explained but those are
limited to like concepts you know now
this being stupid enough to fire the
entire staff of SourceFed and thinking
their channel would succeed explain like
I mean I have those things you know for
my channel but those are ideas those are
concepts they are not like stories and
so what I need is a branding for stories
so I hit up Benny and I was like hey man
you have the complete story I need
something that's identifiably my own and
it doesn't seem like I'm bootlegging you
know a complete story he's like okay
like I'll help you try to figure this
out and then he never did he went rock
climbing I was like okay you know what
if that's how you're gonna be then you
be that way I will I will consult the
rock or I will hit up you guys and we
will try to come together with a name so
that's we're gonna try to do we're gonna
try to think of a name series you know I
guess a name branding for whatever it is
that I do story so it'll be like all-new
all-different marvel to run down you
know do you see rebirth to run down you
know whatever it is or something like
that but we'll figure it out you know
but regardless we pick up now with
Captain America the tomorrow soldier now
those of you guys who are just now
joining comments explain it this is your
first video I promise I never start my
videos off that crazy
sometimes I do but I usually try not to
but but um this is basically Captain
America before the events of all-new
all-different marvel essentially Captain
America before he became a Hydra agent
and the reason why I wanted to do this
is because of the fact that to me this
is very very important this is a very
important aspect of his character in the
sense that this gives us an idea of what
Captain America was about before he
became a Hydra agent and so because of
that we made
we covered dimension Z and then we
covered all the stories after that that
lettuce led us up to here right now and
so with this in mind this is officially
with one Sharon Carter becomes an old
woman and two Sam Wilson becomes Captain
America and these are two of the very
two really really important things but
again the whole idea of Arnim Zola
running dimension Z and having his own
little world unto himself was really a
plot point that I kind of been left
hanging for a couple of stories someone
being because of the fact that Rick
Remender was coming back to it we
basically got Captain America stuck in
dimension Z in the dimension of Arnim
Zola you know he basically raised his
son he escaped and the result was that
Arnim Zola kind of sat in the background
and now he's coming back into the fray
again and this religious comes by way of
an interdimensional invasion now of
course the other half of this is we have
you know this massive soldier of sorts
that's essentially an assassin trying to
track down Steve Rogers on his own now
with regards to Captain America himself
with regards to Steve Rogers himself
he's in a very weird quandary because
remember he's not used to being in a
position where he's so vulnerable
Captain America is used to being in a
position where he's in control where he
knows everything that's going on and if
he doesn't he's surrounded by those who
do in a lot of ways he is here we've got
Nick Fury jr. we've got Maria Hill you
know we've got people who are basically
surrounding him and he has the kind of
resources that he needs but at the same
time he's basically kind of stuck here
in the sense that he's an old man you
know he lost his Super Soldier Serum in
the last video and so because of that he
is not quite the Captain America Steve
Rogers that were used to and in a lot of
ways is kind of stuck on the back burner
now the other half of this is that
apparently sam wilson and jet black the
daughter of Arnim Zola got together and
this is kind of funny because Sam Wilson
wakes up and starts panicking and he's
like no this is workplace involvement
this is not a good idea we're not
supposed to be doing this now again this
is kind of cool because in a lot of ways
Sam Wilson showed a lot of traits of
Steve Rogers himself now it doesn't mean
that Sam Wilson was designed to be a
clone not by any standard of measurement
when Marvel first introduced Sam Wilson
he was his own character he had his own
moral compass his own belief system but
they followed almost exactly in line
with what Captain America stood for you
know in terms of super heroes and
sidekicks running into the modern era
they were really the last bit I mean it
was it was the last the last fig leaf so
to speak in the sense that there were no
more superheroes a sidekicks by the time
we got around to this era but we
maintained
Captain America we maintained
sam wilson these are things that really
seem to work well for their character
they were kind of like the one-two punch
of the avengers leadership role and so
because of this we ultimately end up
finding out that with Arnim Zola you
know basically invading the planet Earth
that Tony Stark and a handful of others
have also done a litany of
investigations and research on to Steve
Rogers and there's no trace of the Super
Soldier Serum inside of his body now
this is actually really kind of cool and
this makes sense because this is
basically Rick Remender saying there's
no possibility of Captain America Steve
Rogers becoming a super soldier again by
way of the Super Soldier Serum now right
now an all-new all-different marvel for
those three guys who were reading that
yes he is young yes he does he is a
super soldier I mean he's got super
strength and all that kind of good stuff
that is because of the fact that the
cosmic key was used to alter him he was
not reinjected with a Super Soldier
Serum he did not undergo project rebirth
again it's just reality warping and so
we kind of have to believe that once
this all comes to an end once the whole
idea of the secret Empire event
basically closes out that Steve Rogers
will likely go back to being old again
now I'm sure he'd just be a really old
grumpy man but still he'll go back to
being old again now the other half of
this is that he is not entirely
defenseless I mean he's got a cane and
sure he can put on a show of looking
like he doesn't necessarily know
everything that's going on but he's
still pretty capable of defending
himself the issue here is that we have
this lone assassin who shows up from
Dimension Z working into the building
now this is cool because it's almost
like Bruce Lee's Game of Death right I
mean he just starts going through the
tower fighting different martial artist
fighting different styles of martial
arts ultimately leading him up to Kareem
abdul-jabbar who for whatever reason
people thought would be legit martial
artists and the result is that it kind
of turns into this weird awkward fight
but the fact remains here that this
assassin rising up and facing off
against this core group of the Avengers
it's really just kind of him going
against Thor going against Ironman and
going against the Incredible Hulk
but each time he's able to outmaneuver
them and outfight them now the beauty of
this is that it is a direct reflection
of how to overcome these individual guys
and the way this works is just by the
idea of what would you stand in the way
of Thor's hammer if you can just jump
over it I mean at the end of the day
sure only the worthy can pick it up but
still it's just an it's an inanimate
object you might as well be throwing a
cup or throwing a rock all you have to
do is just dodge out of the way if you
can dodge a wrench you can dodge a ball
no Meah
with the Incredible Hulk it's the exact
same way he's extremely strong and he
would be at the absolute crap out of
this guy if he could get his hands on it
and so what this shows us is that this
assassin is wildly capable in terms of
what it is that he can do and as he goes
toe-to-toe with each and every one of
these guys ultimately he catches up to
Steve Rogers and Steve Rogers is
actually the guy who incapacitates him
and that's the cool thing because his
basically Rick Remender saying hey look
guys yes Steve Rogers is an old man you
know yes he's grizzled yes he takes naps
but the idea here is that he's still
very much able to defend himself he's
still very much able to engage in combat
with different people so it's still kind
of cool to see that despite the fact
that he's old he's not entirely helpless
but ultimately we actually end up
finding out that this guy is his son Ian
pns survived his entire experience in
dimensions II now the way that Rick
Remender does this is really kind of
messing with us I mean that's one of the
things that Remender did in a lot of
different ways he would play on
comic-book tropes and one of the things
that he does here easy basically says oh
well you know where we thought Ian was
dead he actually fell into a huge vat of
this bio material that was used to
create him in the first place which
basically just healed his wounds and
then spit him back out again so let's
look okay whatever man-- I guess it
works the reason why I'm why I'm on
board with that the reason why I'm
perfectly fine with it is because
Remender does not do that consistently
he's not one of those writers he always
just kind of invokes these MacGuffins
all the time and it's just like hey I
wrote myself into a hole time for reply
device you know he doesn't really do
that all the time he's really good at
building character really really good at
telling stories and so is coming book
readers we usually just kind of give him
a pass don't worry about you know don't
do it again but don't worry about it you
know we don't really mind too much but
the fact remains here that with regards
to Sam Wilson himself this is when he
begins to display the attributes of what
it is that makes a person qualified to
be Captain America alongside jet black
they basically delve headlong into the
base of Arnim Zola and the reason why is
because of the fact that within this
base are essentially the breeding pens
the pens that Arnim Zola uses to make
these massive numbers of soldiers and so
on and so forth now he's also kind of
made his own grotesque kind of
disfigured version of the Avengers and
the form of these different monsters and
while Sam Wilson and jet black are able
to overcome these guys that once they
get to the actual pens themselves we end
up finding out
that within one of the prison cells is
Sharon Carter now this is the reason why
Sharon has grown so old full of the guys
who were reading all-new all-different
marvel right now because I saw this
question a few times in some of the
videos that I posted I figure we go
ahead and do this just for the sake of
answering it but one of the questions
people had is how did Sharon Carter get
old why is she an older woman now when
previously before all-new all-different
marvel she was a woman that couldn't be
but in her 20s maybe early 30s well the
reason why is because of the fact that
remember in dimension Z time passes
faster and so while Captain America
Steve Rogers was only in dimension Z for
30 minutes to his mind he was there for
12 years with Sharon Carter it's the
same way she was there for a little bit
longer save maybe a few hours or so
maybe even a day but for her years past
something close to maybe like 20 years
now what this is designed to do or at
least what it seems like Rick Remender
intended to do was kind of fast-track
the age of Sharon Carter so that he
could turn around and parish and Carter
and Steve Rogers back up together again
and the reason why is because of the
fact that if Sharon Carter was basically
out of the equation at the time the
Steve Rogers lost his Super Soldier
Serum and then suddenly he ages to like
80 years old or something like that
well then he couldn't date Sharon Carter
who's 30 like a 50 year age gap would
just be weird and so because of that by
basically throwing her in dimensions II
keeping there for some measure of Hahn
he can bring her back out and then
suddenly she's 60 or 65 or maybe even 70
something along those lines you know she
looks like she's kind of in her in maybe
her 40s or 50s but nonetheless he can
basically you know age her to the point
that it's reasonable that her and Steve
Rogers would still have some measure of
attraction and they could still share
some measure of a life together and so
with her being brought back here again
it's very shocking for Sam Wilson
because remember when when it was
presumed that she died Steve Rogers life
just came crashing down I mean he was
just like there's no reason for me to be
here anymore
you know I had a son for 12 years now
he's gone Sharon Carter the love of my
life she's gone he'll I don't know what
to do being a superhero anymore the
community's fractured Avengers are
fighting Avengers Avengers are fighting
x-men and the incursions are happening
so remember but this takes place during
the events of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers so if the incursions are still
happening at the time the story's being
written Earth's still crashing into each
other so it's really kind of cool to see
this whole LA this whole scenario take
place but the fact remains here you know
with regards to Arnim Zola himself
things end with him you know quick fast
and in a hurry
Rick Remender really does
not waste a lot of time with Zola
himself this all really just kind of
descends down into a fight between you
know Arnim Zola and the Avengers and
then eventually you know Arnim Zola and
Sam Wilson and that's really about it
now at the time that this is happening
what ends up happening here at least
what we end up finding out is that Arnim
Zola are having all these different
forces go against the Avengers are a
distraction the real goal of Arnim Zola
is to basically have these soldiers
fight the Avengers and then use the
machinery of his antenna to
telepathically communicate with his
soldiers to steadily begin to fall back
not to just run back to the building but
to kind of take a step back and fight
and then a step back and fight and what
that will do is it'll slowly lead in the
Avengers and the reason why is because
within this major facility is a bomb
that will wipe out the entirety of the
city and anybody in its immediate
vicinity ideally it'll destroy the
Avengers and so with 30 seconds left
with his bomb being known about the
antennas ripped off and it initiate a
30-second failsafe
which leaves of course the Sam Wilson
grabbing the bomb and then racing off
into space after which the bomb explodes
now with this conflict more or less over
Arnim Zola manages to sort of sway his
daughter jet block back to his side by
essentially saying hey look you know in
the moment when the superheroes could
have used you the most they kind of cast
you aside to a degree you and Sam Wilson
kind of shared a love for one another
but he basically sacrificed his life in
order to save the superhero community
you had feelings for Captain America but
as soon as Sharon Carter comes back he
kicks you to decide it's really just
kind of playing on the fact that she's
very unsure of herself as she's in a
very confused state because she's not
from the main Marvel Universe she's from
dimension Z and so but kind of preying
on these different aspects that were
kind of preying on her as a whole
basically saying things like I genuinely
need you you're my only daughter someone
has to lead my forces you're the only
one capable of doing it you're the only
real warrior that I know ultimately this
leads to her kind of swaying back to his
side now at the same time of course we
actually end up finding out that Sam
Wilson survived the experience now we
don't know how and we're not really told
how we're just kind of told that he
survived the explosion presumably
because of the fact that he just kind of
flew into space
push the bomb out of the way and then
just sort of crash back down and we
don't really need a great big huge
grandiose explanation now and truth I
would imagine that half of this is
because of the traditional style of
Republic Remender in terms of how he
tells stories in the sense that he
basically leaves a lot of the mortar
between the bricks kind of leaves it to
us
to figure out what
because of the fact that Marvel probably
pushed the initiative for Sam Wilson to
become Captain America and so when
editorials basically telling you Steve
Rogers needs to leave you can only
really show so much interest in that
before you just your story kind of
reflects a slight irritation now I may
be putting words in the mouth of Rick
Remender it may very well be that he was
the one that made the call I haven't
been able to find any interviews where
he basically said I'm the one that came
up with it although um you know those
may very well exist out there but the
fact remains here that with jet black
going to meet with the Avengers despite
the fact that she was able to sort of
stay away at least a little bit from her
father's side uh with C father's
basically saying look we're gonna have
to get all of this figured out you know
with with your father and the whole nine
yards we need you to surrender your
weapons so that we can investigate
what's going on and do a little more
research this results in her basically
saying you guys still don't after
everything she's done you know you guys
still don't trust me and so that's
really the straw that broke the camel's
back it's a lack of trust and it's Ruth
she's actually right about that I mean
she fought alongside Sam Wilson she
fought alongside the Avengers
she put her trust and confidence in
Captain America he put his trust in hers
but in the moment of truth when the
question came down am i with them or on
am i against them they basically said
well how you feel is irrelevant we do
not view you as an Avenger and so with
that in mind she basically just walks
away she just completely takes off bails
out and rejoins her father now of course
what this does is transition to about a
week later now this is where things get
a little murky in the realm of Marvel
Comics and the reason why is because of
the fact that this story came out in in
October of 2014 but in June of 2014
original sin number 3 came out now the
reason why I say that's important is
because of the fact that in the original
sin story it basically dealt with the
idea that everything The Watcher had
ever seen had kind of been broadcast out
to the world and it was a way for Marvel
she does kind of write these little
stories introduce these little retcons
and things like that for characters that
nobody ever knew about before with
regards to Steve Rogers he had basically
learned that when the incursions first
started happening and the Illuminati of
you know Doctor Strange and in Black
Bolt of the Inhumans and you know Tony
Stark and all these different guys that
they had basically wiped his mind you
know and removed his knowledge of the
fact that they were going to leave and
start traveling around in destroying
worlds uh he saw that in an in really an
original sin number three and so at the
time this story takes place Steve Rogers
knows he was betrayed by the aluminum
at the time this story takes place
chronologically Steve Rogers should not
be allied with Tony Stark he should not
be allied with dr. strange
he shouldn't be allied with these guys
he should be hunting them down and
tracking them down and so again this
creates a little bit of a continuity
error nothing wildly significant there
are stories that crop up from time to
time that kind of contradict everything
that's going on but in truth we can
really just kind of ignore that we can
really just kind of say how it goes
whatever you know and then just sort of
read the rest of the story for what it
is but essentially what happens is
Captain America calls together everyone
who has ever been an Avenger you know
and essentially says look I have led
this team for years and years and years
and years but the issue here is that I
am now an old man
I've lost the Super Soldier Serum I
cannot fight out on the battlefield and
so because of this he basically steps
back and says I can no longer be Captain
America instead somebody needs to take
my place and that person is going to be
Sam Wilson who he officially becomes
Captain America for the very first time
now the reason why this was so debated
among fans is because in their mind and
a lot of forum posts and a lot of
different things I saw it on Twitter the
whole time the idea was just because
Steve Rogers can't fight doesn't mean
that he can't be Captain America Captain
America is as much of a leader as a
years of soldier keep the Captain
America costume and just be in the
background dishing out orders monitoring
everything from the background that's
exactly what he does in the early days
of Sam Wilson he just kind of sits in
the back thank God Sam Wilson in terms
of what it means to become Captain
America that was really one of the
solutions a lot of fans came up with
just because he can't fight doesn't mean
he can't be Captain America but again a
lot of those were really Steve Rogers
purist I didn't want to see anybody else
but Steve Rogers play Captain America
which is fine I mean I feel the exact
same way when it comes down to a lot of
the characters that I know and love you
know I don't want to see anybody be this
century but Robert Reynolds you know I
don't want to see anybody leading the
x-men but Charles Xavier I don't want to
see anybody undertake the role of
magneto except for magneto himself I'm
kind of like that you know when it comes
to different characters and teams and so
again it's just really kind of one of
those staples but what this story does
is it basically dead ends and goes
directly into all-new all-different
marvel
we can literally just ignore last days
and all that stuff we can stop here and
go into all-new all-different marvel and
so again it's sort of interesting in
terms of how it all comes together but
if you guys are
new here to come this explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the raw pork if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like do not forget these secret Empire
playlists will be down in the
description that will have everything
you need
going up to really Captain America's Sam
Wilson and Captain America Steve Rogers
we will add to that we will add stuff
like The Avengers we will add Avengers
standoff we will add a lot of stories
that kind of lead up into secret Empire
Civil War too will be in that playlist
Inhumans vs. x-men will be in that
playlist will do a lot of things that
will lead up to that that story and give
us a lot of interesting information but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end and I'll
catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you